okay
people joining this live stream i
seem to be live streaming my whole
afternoon here i just spent a bunch of
time
telling stories about the history of
science and technology and here we are
back at my day job uh working on
language development for language so we
have a variety of topics here
unicode characters via the icu library
okay what is all of this
nick yeah so we're basically running
through
we have been using the icu libraries for
some utilities in wolfram language for a
while now
and i was working with francisco and
danielle on
or daniel on trying to
inventory what things are in the library
that we don't currently have in wolfram
language
and danielle pointed out that
this icu character data function
repository function is kind of a
template of
taking some existing functionality that
exists
for analyzing and getting information
about characters that we don't
entirely have in the language right now
and i think
some of the utilities probably belong in
our character name function
some of them probably go into the
entity domain character as additional
properties and some of them
may be worth having as standalone
functions or integrating elsewhere
but okay let's take a look broken down
here
have you got proposals for these things
yeah so in the
agenda basically the the library
supports
three name properties we already have
the primary one
which exists in character name
as unicode name it gives the formal
unicode name
but there's two extensions to that that
icu provides one is a name
alias which basically is a special case
for some
inputs that have either formally been
given other names in the past or there
may be but we would normally call that
alternate names in our
system yeah it and there is an alternate
name
property in character data or the the
character
domain and entity but it doesn't
necessarily account for these
some of them are basically errors in the
past in unicode that have been corrected
and there's also you know we could
basically extend
this in alternate names for
the entity domain and the extended name
is a
naming scheme for handling unnamed
unicode
character spaces so things where there
isn't a formal unicode name but there's
basically a schema for naming
either white space characters or other
characters well but also
there may be in private unicode space
there may be companies
right that was going to be my first
question which is what does this do in
the pua
what's puy private user yeah
so if if you give it i mean right
this wfr function does this already
right
so or does it not i mean the
the wfr function isn't published i think
primarily because it only runs on
linux right now maybe danielle you can
jump in here
or well that's a bit of a problem
it's why it's just a template ref page
at the moment
okay so so we we don't we can't find out
the answers to these questions but
i i would be curious like if you gave it
like uh
uh i can run you need me to run this in
linux i can run this
linux it returns private use area
character
so okay yes okay
but but look what you're saying is i
mean
the fact that there may be erroneous
error bad
names why don't we just put in that an
alternate names bucket
that's what we do elsewhere
yeah i mean i think there there is a
space to put that
in character data in and any value
um i don't know if there
are other cases i'm missing on name
aliases here but that was the the
primary use case that i was aware of for
it so
right it may be redundant there and i
don't know if the extended names would
just be another
instance where we'd want to have those
as alternate standard names
um sorry the name which is alternate
stand name so this is apparently what it
does
that's pretty boring i mean
you might want something where we query
is it a private use thing or is it
you know is there a notion in unicode of
it's a public use of private use
just essentially that boolean
and i don't know for the extended
unicode stuff
well i i think uh i i think there are
at least three categories you'd want
there right you'd want public private
and unassigned
okay well fine i mean unicode
status or unicode
um
okay let's um
non-missing property association what is
this
so this is just giving a sample of what
the existing
character domain and entity value
populates
and then i didn't know we had glyphs so
so if i say
really i can do this if i say something
like um
you know like my favorite greek
character say
um
oops glyph of that
where are we i had no idea so if i say
graphics of that
wow cool what font are these things in
francisco do you happen to know i don't
remember yeah
i'm not sure if we populated that for
all the letters but yes it's
something we have to add for this
graphical game
um
oh those are characters yeah okay so
they render like that
why do we not given that we have the
glyph why don't we have an image as well
just a canonical image
in which font that would be well what
font is this
this okay all right uh
splatteroo what happened here
an era of unspecified nature yes so you
created uh
uh and what an invalid
unicode character an invalid code point
not all not all values below 65
535 are valid because they might be half
of uh what's called a surrogate pair so
if you've managed to create
half of a surrogate pair and
[Music]
the why does it pink why would i have a
blank box or something left
because that's a very hard problem to
fix
um because it's it's there's no way to
transmit it because it's not
valid unicode
so basically once we extended beyond the
basic multilingual plane we had to
you know start using more robust
unicode
transfer encodings and there's no way to
validly transfer
this half of a character
so uh we were agreed that there is a
problem to be fixed here it's just not
an easy problem to fix
why is it that when i do copy paste it's
not copying anything
i'm going crazy i'm copying that and i
paste it and it's blank
probably because of the bad character oh
but i mean am i copying it into another
application can somebody capture this
please
yeah i get it okay
um well that's funky and
and and there's a bug report about this
uh the problem is it's hard to fix and
it would require
you know a fair amount of coordination
between me and john and so
you know okay well fine but but i mean
it's
the fact that it's actually a syntax
error is very curious but now those
question mark question marks there
so um
what's happening oh that
that's very very civilized okay
by the way do we have any control over
how that question mark thing is rendered
i don't think so but
that's a question for john
okay if somebody could ask that question
if we do have control we should think
about a different design
but if we don't have control then
there's nothing we can do okay so what
are the questions here
examples of existing data okay
yeah and so this is basically just
looking at the properties that are in
icu character data
some of them like block is a property
that already exists in character but
combining classes direction and writing
script aren't
they should probably be populated there
yeah they should be and then there's a
handful of predicates that are on the
function resource page that i don't know
if they should be folded
in you know fold case is kind of an
interesting case of
you know if it's uppercase switch to
lowercase if it's lowercase switch to
upper
and the difference between title case
and uppercase is
a little interesting well what are the
cases where that one i mean
what which characters distinguish those
right well i mean i there there is
another question here right which is
that we use
pcre's definitions of these things
for all of our actual string processing
functions
so do we want to introduce a second
possibly distinct
definition for all these things i mean
we have lowercase character right and
and whatnot as right i thought we did
our own
i mean lowercase character q
lowercase q rather and if i do that for
okay okay
so i thought we had our own tables for
lowercase q
which are based on the pcre tables i
mean
we we have the pcr e tables to which we
have added
uh our private use characters
but um this is still all based on pcre
okay but so and you say that doesn't
agree with ic
the icu i don't think in all cases
yeah we should check but
so without knowing what the what the
disagreeing cases are i don't think we
can say much more about
it if we knew what they were we could
understand why they disagree i mean
maybe
who knows maybe it's real world politics
making them disagree i have no idea
okay the mirror image character
equivalent
that's kind of interesting i mean if
they have it we might as well have it
paired bracket we might as well have it
make sense i mean guys
nick so you say
all this should be properties in
character data yeah character entities
yeah why not next so exactly
yeah yeah i'm here sorry i was muted
yeah i mean i think
basically i wanted to sort out you know
some of these are things that should be
inserted in character data
we can probably there's a big table of
predicates right after that
they could be in character data i don't
know if any of them some of them exist
as standalone
functions i don't know that
you know illegal cues obviously not
going to be a function on its own but
illegal character cue or character code
might be useful or if there's a mirrored
character
these could basically all just get
pushed over into character data
but i didn't know 100 if that's where we
want everything to end up and just say
we're aligning these and where there's
differences between pcre
and icu we'll have to evaluate them on a
case-by-case basis
so what does illegal character queue
like how would that even be useful
well it's one of the characters that
pinked it right
all right but but but okay fine but you
can't
i mean i suppose that exists in the
kernel but there's no way
currently there's no way to type that
character into a front end and
get it all the way to the colonel i mean
that's quote unquote character
by the way reporting something
maybe you get these kind of characters
yes
yes indeed
um yeah well i i don't think we should
be
dealing with that until we decide the
more general issue of how we're dealing
with these
characters in general in in
going right it's fine but now
the question of whether if unicode
itself defines something to be uppercase
or lowercase i think it might be
interesting to have a property
like unicode lowercase q
but see we don't have any q character
any q things
and do we in the case of of uh of a
character entity
no we don't have any of these q
properties
none of these am i jumping up and down
and saying how excited i am about them
um by the way is this not working across
platform because we need a a compiled
binary to be able to access the library
yes okay well so fine so that there are
known solutions to that using
library link and etc we should try to
use them
okay what are you guys suggesting here
to as far as i'm concerned
adding a few from here makes perfect
sense to me
adding the ones like mirror image
character paired bracket character and
so on those all make sense to me
um and and nick correct me if i'm wrong
but we do currently already
link icu directly into the kernel right
yeah we do and right so then while you
right so then the correct solution is
you
you write the mc code to access the
additional
stuff i mean right to make it a
subterranean function which can be
exposed in the function repository yeah
we can we can certainly do that okay
okay so i think that's what we should do
though yeah so this was basically just
part of the effort of of delving through
everything in icu and making sure we're
taking advantage of the things that are
there and not just leaving low hanging
fruit
so excellent are we
i mean okay we've got functional
positive things but i'm i'm curious what
earth rotation data
is um um i mean
we have 12 more functions to go in the
world from functional repo collection
and we have danny and rick for that
discussion okay
well fine but what are the solar time
things what are those are those easy to
discuss
uh i think so it's i have some questions
there about
naming so these are half-baked functions
so so they are still much under progress
but uh there are some naming decisions
to make
particular more particularly in the
other one in error rotation data
which actually and now i will be
suggesting we call it earth orientation
data
to be more general that seems very very
obscure
i mean just as a name okay
yeah so this okay so
should we go to this one so so the idea
is that
there is um this organization the iers
international earth rotation service
and they are monitoring everything that
relates to the orientation of the earth
with respect to the celestial reference
system
and they have very very interesting
information like
the duration of the earth the how the
rotation pole is moving on the earth
everything related to the various time
systems etc
so it's very interesting information and
fundamental for working astronomy
so there are many properties and there
are things like
you see these differences of time how to
name those
or the real question that i have
is how long is it before we also need
moon rotation data
uh well i think i think we should not
worry about it i think i think
it'll be it'll be a long time before
anybody cares about this for something
other than the earth
i've seen papers discussing the same
problem with mars already
but not for other planets
so right you want to have an observatory
there you really need to have control
on your moving frame
i see so if there's an observatory on
the moon people will care about it then
exactly because if they they need to
know the orientation of the moon with
respect to the
stars in order to to point a telescope
right it would be lovely if the name
could not doesn't have earth in it
but i mean where we could have like geo
era
no no no but i mean when we say geo
position
and we can say moon you know we're okay
geo might mean the earth but
it's okay it's not it's not totally
crazy
geo-rotation data
or is it astro rota now it's too weird
so the the main parameters here which
are five
they are always called earth orientation
parameters that is standard nomenclature
that's why
i see
and and this is truly about the earth
at the moment but yes so um
well i mean it's going to be a long time
before it's about anything else but but
but the orientation data
could be geo rotation i like it less
because i was planning to offer
rotation actually yeah go ahead yeah so
i was trying to have a
geo-rotation function at some point that
performs rotations
of polygons on the surface of the earth
you mean about some point like rotate
the us around new york or something
uh for example so the general rotation
has three parameters
but on the surface of the earth it has
only one
well it's it's two as you said you
specify the point
and the angle of rotation around that
point so you have three friends
so it's basically like a rotation in the
plane why isn't it the same as rotation
on the plane
i mean except it's applied to the geoid
um well because you have
exactly you have to apply it on a curve
on
on the ellipse side so it's it's
non-trivial
right but if you want for example to
compare two planets super pose sorry two
planets two countries
superpose one on top of the other then
you need to perform a rotation
so that one goes on top i would have
thought we should take a
rotate translate all those operations
and simply
have a way in which those can be done in
a geo situation
because i can see those functions being
also useful at some time in the future
when we have a representation of some
random
algebraic surface or something you know
translate this triangle around
around this weird algebraic surface
but no those functions are very tied to
the flat geometry i don't think we can
generalize them to other
cases okay on the earth already the
concepts of rotation
and translation are merged
the translations are should infinity
infinite sorry
what do you mean translation 3 isn't
that our geo
what is it geo direction and so on dear
displacement yes
yes yes but that's that's displacing
i mean you can displace all points in
the same direction
but they are not going to be i see
parallelism exactly exactly right
right okay you may end up with something
much smaller for example
i kind of favor geo geo orientation data
that's that's it seems about the right
level of technical
and um so solar time is
goes along with like unix time and
absolute time and all those kinds of
things right
so the real time said real time yeah
sidereal time is already a thing
right and if i say now minus
no there is an example that i think in
the page that we'll explain
so sidereal time is a it's a quantity
it's an angle
so both solar time and satirial times
are actually angles are angles
of rotation right relative to whatever
the first point of areas or whatever the
crazy thing is
exactly sidereal time is is rotation
with respect to the stars
solar time is rotation with respect to
the sun yeah which is important
unfortunately we have to we call it time
and yet it's an angle
it's a tradition yes i mean if i say
unit convert
that to degrees
angular degrees string
be nice if i could just say degree
wouldn't it
um not really because
degree is a number i see
i see this is a unit
okay so so solar time
is the same thing it's an angle it's
that
but it will be written in
right ascension or whatever this is or
something
exactly so look at the first basic
example of the page
i see so it's off by only a little bit
from gmt
exactly i think it's the maximum is
about 16 minutes
sorry um
no i'm saying this wrong so once you
take into account
time zones there are places in
west china which are displaced almost
four hours
but when you compare solar time to
uh the the correct time that you would
have there with your proper time zone
then it's much smaller well right if the
time zone was allocated correctly it
would be plus or minus an hour
exactly yeah so here in champaign we
happen to be very very close to our
proper time zone
and that's why it matches so nicely
okay cool all right
well this looks like a fine function so
it'll be location
and date yeah exactly we have the
precedence for
so the the interesting thing here is
that there are two concepts of solar
time this
was it called apparent time and another
one mean time
yes and so i was i mean here i'm
suggesting a method option
but in some other functions we have had
a string
as an argument so i'm not sure
we need to do the same thing for
sidereal time it there it also has two
versions
mean and apparent
um local mean time
what is that what what is the so the
apparent time is the time that you see
when you look at the sun or or the the
sun sorry
the time that the sun dial would give
you that's the true it's also
called true time to lose all of time
but that is changing inhomogeneously
so what they have done is to compute a
mean an average
it's like a fictitious sun that moves at
constant speed through the sky
yes and that's the that's what is called
mean time means
our time and that m is the m of gmt
right well i mean but those are really
very different things i mean
to me it seems like
it's a pity we can't just say solar time
of mean
time type thing to get that
because it feels like it it feels more
than a method option
we could have a string for example we do
something similar in
julian date in which there is a string
at the beginning specifying the type of
julian date
i see oh i see so we do this well then
we should do the same thing for solar
time
this hackaroo where we have either a
date or a string as the first argument
do you prefer that i think so i mean
from what i understand of solar time and
the significance of mean time versus
other things
okay so those are those ones cool
all right okay do we have to for geo
orientation data so i i would like one
particular question so using this table
of
of properties there are these
differences of time
and those are fundamental so i mean
is it possible to have this minus there
or should i write minus
well how do people usually write it
um with a minus yes they say this this
is
thai minus ut1 but of course here we
have string which is a bit
odd yeah i understand i'm not a big fan
of the minus in there
i mean we could say thai ut1 difference
it'll look a little bit funky though
because it'll be that will all be
um yes and and it's a bit
ambiguous what do we mean by difference
in which order
oh gosh so i mean we can write minus in
between
right like that
i would kind of prefer that by the way
could we can we return
oh i see t a i
eventually will have a function that
returns the ut one time right
um so what we are going to have is data
object taking a time system
which is this ti a t a i ut1 utc
etc and then date object will report the
right time
i see so that so eventually i will be
able to say tai i'll be able to compute
that difference explicitly
by a difference of data objects is that
true no
because data object is absolute data
object of the same time
so how to say if you put the same data
list in the first argument update object
then yes
yeah right exactly but if you say data
observer of
now comma time system goes to something
minus data object of now
time system goes to something that's the
same now so that should report zero
right yep i see what you're saying right
but otherwise
it's like there is a defamation given
a given this
at this in this coordinate system
three means something different from
what it does in that coordinate system
exactly and the difference is this thing
that we are reporting here
right and the return value the
conceptual return value of date
object is an absolute time that is
relative to whatever it's relevant
relative to but it will be absolute for
both of them and so it will report the
genuine difference
exactly right
comment on our live stream that the
indian system is lunar solar calendar
yep we we know all about this can we
can we show off and do what can we do
calendar data of what kind of calendar
do we want here
um yeah we have the uh no no no no
that's not there
so what we want here is uh date object
of uh calendar type goes to
um how's it called nick indian
the modern hindu oh my exactly more than
hindu
it's not auto completing guys uh that
got fixed just recently
it was in the queue for auto complete
your modern
hindu lunasolar
lunisola yeah because there's a solar
version too
i think it's with lower cases
there you have it 1472
2077. well what happened in
okay let's not go there 77 bc or
something
was that a notable time i have no idea
um go ahead that must be something but
okay i'm looking good
looking really good okay um
okay yeah so yeah if you go down some
some examples there are some
they're really interesting interesting
on on the duration of
of a given day or
yeah that's some plots it's really
interesting yeah
oh wow okay so that's that's um
how probably does this go atomic when
the atomic clocks were invented probably
exactly in the 60s but then there is
inferred data from eclipses going
thousands of years back
how are we dealing with that well um
yeah we have interpolative functions
but so if i ask for this so
yeah in this example i i don't have much
going back but i do have the data
and and this is what the poll is doing
are what the rotational poll is doing
around the geographic pole
it's it's moving a few minutes units oh
those are meters
yep okay
question do we support metric time what
is metric time
some napoleonic invention metric time
we we do have the french calendar
the right with 100 days or something
whatever it is 10 day weeks
exactly unless they mean
and such i mean that was a metric time
system
but yeah but not for the earth i would
imagine
um okay this is really nice uh
um
okay
so let's go on with the function
repository review yep
okay
ah this is a metric timer 10 hours per
day brilliant
i don't think show me who cares and then
we'll decide whether i mean maybe
good function repository function
um okay let's take a look at these
we have copied a clipboard yes no
that was me trying to test what this
function does i see but we don't have
copy from clipboard which is what this
is
right we have paste
which is able to place the
um the content as new input but but
nothing that
returns as output i think
i say well time's useful to me
seems quite useful to me
to do it again
this worked for me before now do
copy to click bar and then
okay and then is that an expression or
is that
what what is that should be a string
right
so it's always just a string look really
this should be something like clipboard
import
i mean in in um because what you're
going to want to do with the clipboard
where would you use this you would use
this if you're interacting with an
external program
and it says
i'm not sure when you would use this i
mean
right i i suppose you might and like in
certain user interfaces
right you might say you know copy what
you want to the
clipboard and then click here for the
next step
but right and then i guess it's not so
clear if you want it as a string or as
well i don't think you wanted to
distract me i think you want a more
complicated thing because i think the
clipboard
if it's genuinely the clipboard contains
all kinds of other stuff like the html
version of the clipboard and so on
right i think clipboard important will
be nice in the sense for example a use
case
i had yesterday i was i had a table in
some excel
and i wanted to copy that into
mathematica so i could copy then it was
a string and i could do import string of
this as table
but clipboard import directly from what
is in the memory
and put as format table for example that
would be nicer
you mean if if right but so but but one
thing is
to pick up the non-string version of
what's on the clipboard
june so i'm saying the operating system
lets you do that to make an association
or to say clipboard import and then to
say you know because there's an html
clipboard i don't know what exactly
right and
right and the right and of course if if
what you copied from is mathematica
there will also be the true
you know cell expression or box
expression
version on the clipboard yeah
i mean this this seems to me maybe it's
more like clipboard data
but the the idea of a clipboard of a
thing that can pick up as an association
whatever is on the clipboard seems
useful to me
the named you know elements on the
clipboard
i think that's useful i mean we've got
to ask somebody in a different group how
to do this
right i mean
[Music]
this is not a conversation to be had in
detail without john
yeah all right image colorize
well let's see what let me pick up an
example here
um see whether i believe it
i mean let's see what that she does in
practice all right here's an example
you have something in black and white i
do okay
good black and white example here
there's our friend mr sean finkel and
his paper
see what we do
i mean i i already have a function that
does this or could be extended to do
this i feel like this is
right like we have image effect so
wouldn't
there's a function called colorize
well i'm not very impressed with what
this did here
um what does color colorize takes
what did that do
it's more attractive than this one
oh generates an image from an integer
matrix using colors for positive
integers in black for non-positive
integers
well i think there's a clear question of
whether
colorize right needs um an
additional method or a method option or
something or a second argument or some
such other thing
but i don't really understand i mean
this is not impressive what this did
here
i mean this is a picture of a person we
know that very few people are that color
the examples in the in the wfr
page are more impressive
well question is what
i have no clue how i mean
i don't know i don't know
let me let me pick an example okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna pick a um
uh okay hold on let's say
picture of an ostrich now what's a good
cut a toucan how about a toucan
sure you have a picture of a toucan
somewhere
who's to know that that was a a ram from
whatever it is okay how do i do this
color convert
is it monochrome or what's it called
grace girl
grayscale i think yeah okay
toucan and gray
the unexpected species the grey toucan
the which lives in a gray forest it's
been heavily adapted
never mind okay
how does the toucan do the toucan is now
yellow
hmm how did it know it's yellow how did
it know that that two cam was yellow
okay give me another kind of creature
that's a different color how about a
tiger
no how about something um how about
a a gecko i don't think old geckos
what about a chameleon
the a cuttlefish a cuttlefish is a
really good idea yes but even a gecko
there's um that gecko is not green
not all geckos are green
that's my point
in fact i think they they vary with them
okay let's do this
wow well i mean it's vaguely right
i don't know i mean you know
let's just see
i'm i just want to wait until it colors
up a zebra orange or something
um
wow the grain is very impressive
the green is good
um what's a good example
let's find an example um
here let me just find an example
some fruit something very colorful no i
had a different idea
i am going to try this picture works
there we go
let's see whether it puts green on the
ground
or red for that matter
let's see what it does with the flag
okay so it thinks it's in arizona
i have painted bunting
what the heck is that a rainbow colored
bird
okay but anyway it's not it's not
fantastic but it's not terrible
the question is is it actually useful
i'm afraid he lost his colors
i mean this isn't terribly impressive
certainly that's not terribly impressive
one would think that was a recognizable
image
natural things i mean i'm always looking
at the backgrounds
the green backgrounds and i'm very
impressed by that
yeah i think a lot of things are on
green i mean it's like um
uh let's see
okay so for example if i take something
like this
is it going to successfully figure out
that that's blue
i have a thing i mean so what's the use
case yeah
well so so
i mean it had the sky is blue this isn't
terrible
but what's the use case for this really
you take all your old black and white
pictures
yeah but i mean look in the original
case i did hear it
failed right that didn't do much
and um you know that that seems like a
very valid black and white picture of a
person we all know it's person
etc etc um
now sorry let me just get um
uh is does it have any options or
anything does it have i mean intensity
oh i see it has a a um
uh just a wrapper for a net in the
neural net repository
uh where am i putting these
um well
you have a function repository folder
or like a wfr folder yeah i think it's a
different place
let's do it
okay all right well i mean it's amusing
and i think we should look at putting it
as a second argument of current colorize
but that's something for the image
processing team i think
um
oh okay oh okay nick is suggesting that
the in this case the document on the
right might confuse
the network so let's try this maybe i'll
be more
sold
all right i'm colorizing the colorized
image
hmm not too convincing
well it's actually actually that's
better
it's definitely better i mean it's a
little bit ghostly
but not terrible i i just don't know
what this is i mean
look it's an amusing thing for colorize
you know second argument like you know
natural or something yeah
it does make sense to absorb these in
colorize
okay
boy this these pictures are really big
these days
okay context module
that's an amusing suggestion from nick
there i i'm just
urged to do this just because i'm just
because i'm i'm um
so so what does that block set dollar
context path to
actually empty because
that would be quite interesting
what context brought to empty yeah that
that
i was looking at the next function
already i don't know i understand and
and then
and an empty context path leads to
aliens
who are mr sean finkel guts
is
let's just say it's a fun experience or
a unique experience
feel like it reaches a fixed point after
three or four attempts
yeah as opposed to
you know just imagine if we put a
chameleon in here and keeps changing
color as we keep iterating
um
okay why is it taking so long to save my
gosh
maybe these pictures are really huge
wow why is it taking so long it just
seems wrong
um okay context module
to unique empty context to a unique
empty context it means
set it to some you know
well that's context right so i presume
that means it creates some random
context which hopefully has no symbols
in it
but i don't know what it says dollar
context path to
and it says the context path only
includes that unique context
so not system yeah not not system
so if you have things that are
preemptive like dynamics or whatever you
would want to wrap like
protector on this to be safe
so if i say
something like um table of this
comma three or something
how does that work how does the table
work
because it passes this table before
going into it but if if you had like
oh i got something right right
in your notebook and it was asking the
colonel
at that time
yeah yeah because if if the front end
preempts the kernel while it's in that
context block for example it's not going
to know how to render the boxes
um i was a commentator by the way from
steve on the live stream about data
privacy implications for interaction
with the clipboard
interesting question i mean clearly the
application can interact with the
clipboard
and you can just do paste so at that
level
not really an issue i mean well you know
the issue would be if something is
stealing the clipboard
i don't think unless the application is
in focus i don't think it can do
anything
[Music]
i see what would happen if there was a
background job running that says
what's the contents of the clipboard and
it kept on doing that
well there are there are such
things they're called clipboard managers
and and so you know it'll do whatever it
does to the clipboard you know some are
more elegant than others
no but i'm asking the questions there's
a clipboard import and i can't simply
have it running on my machine just like
i have a key logger running
i would sort of be i could just ingest
and you know i could ingest the content
of the clipboard at any time without me
knowing it
right well the contents of your
clipboard right the clipboard is a per
user no i understand but if i have a
background job running
if i start a wall from engine on my
computer right i just go
and i just go to um uh
sure and and yes and it would just grab
it whenever it executed
no matter whether it was the foreground
processor or not
and that might have consequences for
what's on the clipboard
why would have consequences for what's
on the clipboard i mean so if i go here
and i say in here
i say resource function clipboard
content
okay and i say in here
well that that certainly won't do
anything
in a standalone kernel right because
it's not connected to any front end and
it's not connected to the
um right so you could try it inside of
using front end
um in here yeah
okay i don't understand why this didn't
work i mean in other words
if there's a global clipboard in the
operating system so
this process this background process
should be able to grab
whatever is on my global clipboard right
it uses clipboard notebook so it's
specifically front-end thing
okay right so if yeah so if it needs uh
what is good notebook
i don't think it's actually documented
but it's something you could you can do
notebook yet on it and it'll give you a
notebook
corresponding to the clipboard
oh it is documented
no it's not documented
clipboard notebook with no arguments and
then if you did notebook yet
on that that's that's what uh
clipboard content is processing
okay so i don't understand what this is
apparently that's the current content of
your clipboard
well this is but not the stuff down here
well right it turned it into a notebook
right so
yeah it's just that
what on earth was that that thing all
right so so right so so right the the
the
so it did work inside of the using front
end it's just that right it would the
clipboard was still
what you thought i think right so if you
copy something else and now reevaluate
in the terminal
hopefully you'll get something
non-trivial
oh okay well fine so let's do this
oh you mean boy are you serious that it
was actually that
right because wasn't that the last thing
you copied
okay well that's yep
how did it say mathematica
uh well
this is a bad pasteboard sync error
wow that's well what's dollar
installation directory
maybe you're actually running a
mathematica
nope nope okay well then that's
because it's probably probably because
it's an assertion failure so it's just
heart
hard coded because
right it's a compile time it's pretty
yeah well something else to fix but this
is also a very weird bug
wow interesting bug
that's kind of wild okay did you get
this
yeah yeah i got it okay all right let's
continue here
context module is not quite making it
for me it's kind of obscure
i mean should i should it be making it
for me it seems like it's something that
that is a story of the modern of the
new package format and it need that
needs to be worked out
to know what to do with this i think uh
in the
application section i i've got some
examples that i think show what it
would actually be used for
it's sort of related to the two full
string that was looked at already
just right although
i mean you can just do that by setting
the right options too
right i mean you can you can you can set
the context to be always fully qualified
look the other case is something like a
form an external form
where it is where you know where you
type in x plus y
it comes in as an expression the
question is in what context were x and y
created what answers that
i'm sorry can you repeat the question
okay you do a form
you type in x plus y it's supposed to be
an expression in what context
are x and y created some random
context uh yeah but is it on the context
path so for example for example let me
let me do the following
so let's say i say cloud deploy
of a form function
you know x is an expression
and let's say i say i don't know
derivative of x
with respect to x okay actually let me
not do derivative let's do integral
because it's going to be um
okay
and did you mean those to be
a pound x and then not a pound x i do
mean that
okay well then you'll get zero
well well it was not it's an integral
here well
okay yes integral plus one here right
submit it wow okay the expression
okay how did that work how did that work
i think because in the cloud it's it's
just global context
really it's not unique if i i could
i think that's something that should
probably be done in the interpreter
i think we should allow different forms
of expression depending on
you know uh either an option
or a different named interpreter type
that can unique or not
because actually i'm very glad that that
one worked
um but okay so the question here
i don't really understand the use case
for context module
and again i think this is part of this
is something that should be revisited
when we have the new package format
but again can somebody please make a
note of this thing about expression
could we
think about that whether whether
expression should have a choice for the
unique advice or not
right expression or something like that
and about this context before we move on
a bit
in alpha for example we needed a sandbox
evaluation environment
and we created our own function to do
evaluations that
strip out all the contexts and live on
the system and
its own context to get files etc that
could create symbols
and then we remove them so well i think
that's a different sandboxing question
right so i think that's more useful in
general to have the way to
a way to to evaluate this stuff but i
agree that's that's basically controlled
evaluate
which is evaluate with only certain
resources allowed like no file access
allowed etc etc etc
and i think that will be useful
i mean that that's a long-term project
controlled evaluate
although we have versions of it in the
cloud already
okay there's a question from iron on a
live stream about any chance of getting
3d animations with geo
stuff we do have 3d geo don't we coming
geographics 3d
jose it's in the plans um i mean
we first need to figure out all the
vertical datums and various things but
it's in the works okay
i see so in other words if you're really
close to the surface
and you have a geo elevation well
i'm sure there's an issue of just the
simple show me things on the geoid on
the whole geoid where where
obviously it's invisible that the
duration
difference is invisible on the surface
although not for a satellite or
something
but there are differences of i mean the
geoid in
i think it's it's north atlantic versus
southern india
there are like 200 meters of difference
so
i mean one has to be careful to not make
errors of
of i mean nobody can see that on the on
the whole geoid
you know if you're going to draw the
path from you know how you get from
london to sydney or something
on a picture of a globe you're not going
to see that
right but our zero of zero position zero
is not the same zero as
the uh c level zero
i understand that so i mean it's the
sort of thing in which
people can get tons of large errors if
we don't
provide nice ways of specifying what
they want
yeah like do they want the actual
surface of the geoid at a given place
okay so i see
so geoposition and principle should have
a third argument
if it says x y and automatic that means
the surface of the geoid at that point
it's not it's part of the second it's
part of the datum
so the datum needs to be extended the
datum language has to be extended
to support vertical items
i see i mean i bet there's a wfr
function we could have right now for
globe plot or something
which just does the most obvious thing
of just putting the things
ignoring the geoid and just putting in
our sphere
yes on a sphere and um yeah but but yeah
of course that that would be
kilometers or hours ah absolutely but
but it's irrelevant if you if you're
looking at the whole earth
of the whole thing yes yes absolutely
yeah perhaps we should do that but
by the way are we going to get you know
the analog of geoposition for spheres
like sphere position sphere
i mean sphere uh you know sphere
distance and so on
spherical geometry we have a ticket for
that i think
it's for me just it's not top of my
list of things okay yeah at some point
all right trace interactive
well this is interesting but i think it
seems like a
boy i need to play with this i have no
idea
i mean the whole story of trace
what is this is this you generate the
trace and then you look at this
no well it's tracing it stops on each of
the
the points that you give a pattern for
so you can do things like inspect the
stack and whatnot
but so how does this work
uh
you're basically in a sub-session now so
like if you looked at
uh stack
you evaluated stack bracket bracket i
think you need to click next
door step by step yeah or you you can
evaluate things while it's paused
like that too to like get values of
symbols or whatnot
well this is interesting i mean so what
happens in a more
sophisticated what happens if i just do
that oh i didn't return
i'm dead yeah that's something that's
like welcome
now can't you just return at this point
return bracket bracket oh yeah that
should work
uh apparently not or if you avoid maybe
doesn't return the thing that tells you
to return even from a dialogue
or am i confused just beeping
okay why the beep
oh come on why does it always say this
this is something we should discuss in
the user assistance meeting
i think the way the beat messages have
not been adequately updated over the
years
can we bring that up please user
assistance can somebody look at this
yeah i'll send it along um
all right well i'm toast here so i gotta
quit the cuddle
fortunately i already had to kill a
giant job that i had running
so well i think that in and of itself
is a sign that certainly the current
implementation isn't
ready for prime time even if we decide
we like this functionality
i think the functionality is quite
interesting and i mean it's part of the
whole story of debugging
boy okay there's all kind of let's just
do a very quick look here
and then then i think we have to wrap up
monitor test report that seems
interesting but
it's a good wfr function whether it's a
whether it should be built in
oh i think with the new progress
monitoring stuff
it's probably better to just have that
integrated and test report
sounds right to me set context
style oh that's interesting
what
set context style then what does it do
so it'll change the style of
by uh by any symbol in that context
yeah so by default it'll be global that
like that'll make your global symbols
appear orange
i mean it's interesting i think there
should be some defaults i've talked
about this before about
from other contexts and we haven't
really done that
of making private context a different
color and things like that
well automatic is the wrong thing it
should be inherited
but well i'm sorry what was that what
was i
saying was automatic no i'm saying no no
i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying i'm looking at the example
here and i'm saying
that automatic is wrong it should be
inherited because i
agree i wrote this a long time ago and i
don't think i knew about
inherited back then you clear a style in
the front end as you said it to
inherited
right but but so this functionality of
coloring context let's
let's bring this up in the user
assistance meeting where we've been
discussing
automatic rendering of context names and
things
which i think we should change i think
we should make the context names smaller
and things like that
which would make some code where there
happened to be contexts a lot more
readable
session information
that's interesting i mean system
information it goes along with system
information presumably
if we have system information why don't
we have session information
it's a reasonable point i mean how much
of um the session tab of the option
inspector is here
or is that what this is this is just
some stuff i hand-picked because i was
using it for logging stuff in the cloud
so for like an api function i was just
always dumping this to
a file so i could check when stuff is
going wrong this seems useful
i think we should look at this um who is
the right person to look at this
oh i was muted no wonder you were
ignoring me um
uh this this seems uh i was going to say
a lot of this is repeated in
system information and right
i mean this is i think almost entirely a
subset of system information
so well what is is there a system
information of quote
uh there is not but i think there should
be maybe this is but
but but most of this is first of all
this is mostly
kernel right so if you look it says some
information of kernel i mean it's much
longer but it includes almost all of
that information
it does include some front-end stuff
just because that was useful for my
purposes when i made this but okay so
the the the thing would be a system
information of quote
session that contains a curated list of
things of relevance for the session
well i what what does that mean right
dollar version number
like what does i mean i uh no i think
that's well i don't think
okay what's usefully session specific
actually i'm not sure i know i mean when
did the session start
which we don't have here i sort of think
of this as
system information medium because we
have small which is
you know very lightweight thing but well
then maybe we should add a system
information of medium
yeah that's that's kind of what i think
of it as
fine who's who's in charge of system
information
lou okay
i have no opinion about this do we have
anybody from the geometry team here
i don't know whatever they think about
this is is probably what i think about i
don't know what this
is um
bytes to quantity well the the simplex
founder isn't necessarily geometry
because
it can take abstract simplicities that
don't have coordinates
okay i don't know what this is i mean
this is finding the boundary of
something right
it's a topology thing
well that's you know topology is part of
the roadmap
for the geometry group
so i mean it can't do it for simplex of
abc can it
oh what does it do it probably just
gives
what does it do uh it's
basically it's like how the boundaries
defined with simplicial homology
um yeah i mean you break the thing into
i mean i i know but what does it return
a bunch of line segments oh okay
well this is interesting and directly
relevant to the topology effort
so this is for charles and roger
make sense although i'm not sure why it
would be distinct from region boundary
if you know region boundary could just
understand
symbolic simplicities right that's why
i'm saying it's relevant to those guys
because i don't know
beyond that
this seems like a good function
repository function i don't think this
is a prime time function
i i was thinking it might be nice to
have maybe something in unit convert
like automatic to just put it in quote
nice units
we've talked about that i mean you'd
have to manually wrap it in
byte quantity comma bytes first but
we've talked about
unit convert having sort of that seems
like a good idea but this is something
different this is something which is
taking a plain number
right which is which is why i'm saying
it to do it
with inside of unit convert you need to
manually wrap it in bytes
i fully support the idea of having a way
to use unit converts to give
you know sensible just like we do in
wolfen alpha to give all those
heuristics about what the right
uh you know unit modifier is
and nick why haven't we done that
because it's complicated for general
cases
i mean we've looked at having a you know
convert to nice units
but really what you want to do is have
some presets of what collections of
units you want it to convert to
it's no but that's a different issue is
it kilometers or millimeters
right but if you just have a length you
know if i put in 400
000 feet we probably want to go to miles
if we put
in well no but what we're saying is okay
look
look there's two different issues you
know you're going to meet us but you
want
modified meters you want to write you
you want some
uh whatever the right term would be
prefixed
right prefixed meters right that's
that's one thing you know you want to go
to meters but what
prefix of the meters in alpha we have a
thing called unit click
that allows you to specify um which
subset of units you want to choose the
best from
but it's slow because it has to try them
all to figure out which one's best
right but but i mean in this case what
we would want is something when you're
in kilometers
and you want to convert it but it's it's
not
appropriate for kilometers it's really
millimeters and so
what we really want is a unit convert of
a of a sort of meta unit that's just
called prefix
or something that will change the prefix
but you leave the base unit the same
making sense i mean it's something we've
talked about and
edge cases are complicated common cases
are
more straightforward they're prefixes
that are commonly used with some units
and not with others
i understand i understand we've got a
whole set of heuristics that we worked
out 10 years ago
for this yeah right and i don't know why
we wouldn't just use them
i think it's just a design problem i
mean you know if we say unit convert
comma prefix or something or maybe
there's a different
um
yeah we've talked about it as possibly
going in unit simplify
or having a quantity simplify but yeah
we can we can spin off another business
right and
and well right i mean i think there is
sort of a
distinction here between metric units
and non-metric units right because with
metric units yeah right i like to say
mega miles
right and and also right so with
with with metric units right you could
certainly
say something like uh
you know basic i don't know what we
would call it right but basically you
want it to be
between one and a thousand with an
appropriate prefix or something like
that
right we could call it prefixed meters
right the main problem in design here is
the boundaries what
it is just discussing this is what we
always go to stack
do we because it's just a heuristic time
is a good example
like it yeah it's heuristic but but we
want
a way of specifying modifications of
that
tough luck i mean this is look the fact
is people would use this prefix meters
for example
as a way or
maybe maybe prefixed si
and then you know you're getting it as
no you can't guarantee that you can't
guarantee it's it's the si you know is
it kilogram meters
per second squared or is it joules
right okay but i i think
i think well i i think in general
go ahead right but i think with with
with prefix si anything that is an si
unit
right you give give you know get the
prefixed form of the correct size
but no i understand but we're saying
you're converting a distance to
meters if if it's a base si unit there's
no ambiguity
about what the sr unit that comes out is
length for example
if it's something like mass
length time to the minus two there are
multiple s i
representations of that right
but but but then we would need one for
every single physical
we would need a prefix version of every
single physical quantity no every single
si unit
prefixed meters prefix jewels prefix
that's right but then
and so then just like we right now but
what do you what what do you do then
with cool
with with compound quantities so suppose
you have newtons
and you're converting them to prefixed
meters or or like what would you
order i guess it wouldn't work it
doesn't work okay and so
what does prefixed look right so
right so it only ever works with base si
physical quantities and not with no
other no no you're not understanding
look
look look look if i say here i'm sure i
can say
this to gigameters sure
and i can say that to you know yocto
meters
okay so every one of those is a named
thing right yep okay so what i'm
suggesting is
that this have an alternative form that
says prefixed meters
okay that is simply automatically
picking between yocto meters
you know gigameters etc right but that
that seems
way too limited because what if i have
pounds
no it will convert to look whatever
yeah well wait right pounds our unit of
force
right so there is no si there is no
i mean no it'll give a unit error it
will say
you can't convert a thing right but what
if i want to right i mean
i'm saying you can only if this only
allows you
right this all right prefix meters only
works
with distance and sure we could add
prefix seconds
absolutely we'd rather look just like
right but but that that
that leaves out 99 of all the units
because it's only
no no i'm no listen to what i'm saying
look what happens to what you're saying
okay you don't write yokto
meters well you could i see you're
saying
what what if you have yokto meters per
second
right or nutrients no but but then you
would have prefixed newtons
and then you'd have picometers or
piconewtons or whatever
that's exactly right you would just do
that just like you can say
so every single named unit has a fixed
version
yes because look look look
every single si unit has the actual
prefix
names built in you see what i'm saying i
can have your meters i can have
atometers
i can have nanometers and so on right so
all i'm saying is
you take that bundle of whatever they
are 15 of those things
right and there's an additional one
which is the automatic case
right which instead of yokto meters i
just say prefix meters and it will pick
whether it's yokto or ato or whatever
okay that's what i'm suggesting is that
true that we have
as uh as a as a named unit every single
prefix
si unit absolutely nick
yeah we should have pretty i mean there
are also some prefixed
non-si units like kilo feet is a unit
that gets used sometimes and technically
you can combine them
but we could pretty easily at least scan
through
the unit tables and pick out the ones
that have comprehensive
si prefixes and at least have a preset
of those
again there's maybe a larger discussion
to have about defining custom unit
clicks
for some operation that's a different
issue but you're confusing this
the goal here is to is to convert 13
feet
to something in presumably ordinary
meters whereas if i said
13 times 10 to the 18 feet and and to
convert that to appropriate numbers of
you know
whatever they are gigameters or
something
yeah i mean the other case i think
people would
really like us to handle
and er is time it's time units and
i was going to say i also have seconds
to quantity on the
on the function repository which is
similar but it puts things in a
mixed yes well i think i agree so we
need a named
right hand side for unit convert which
does the right thing
right well for appropriate definitions
of the right thing
okay listen it's a heuristic it's just
like many other heuristics if you don't
like the heuristic you write it
explicitly
we don't want a heuristic that has 75
controls because
it's not you know it's it's quite easy
to write it explicitly
if it's greater than x number of seconds
then do this
otherwise do that it's not difficult to
write that it will be more confusing
to try and tweak some some setting for
your heuristic
okay so this is a good idea this prefix
meters thing is a good idea and we
should implement it
but we already have that somehow right
in the sense that for example i can put
uniconvert quantity 5 miles to metric
and it will give me kilometers
but if i write 0.0005
miles to metric will give me millimeters
well then maybe we have this already
yeah it's it's more limited you know the
the unit systems themselves have
preferred units that don't
typically include all of the si prefixes
you can add
400 million miles and it will still try
and convert them to kilometers
instead of yokta ma octometers or
something
but well so look what i'm suggesting is
named things that either do okay so
there are really two cases here
give it in the range that is right for
the prefix
or give it the way people would actually
write it see what i'm saying
people do not write you know uh yota
meters or whatever is not commonly
written
people don't commonly write astronomical
distances in yotometers
right yotometers um
but because there's a conventional usage
which we have curated
and there is also a theoretical usage
based
on the ranges for these particular uh
prefixes
right both of those are worth having
does that make sense
yeah and both of those should be a named
thing like
i don't know which one is prefixed this
is a michael trott question i'm sure
that people
in the you know in the world of um uh
unit discussions so so in the bite world
how do we distinguish between the gibby
yes i haven't a clue right i'm sure
there's a way to do it i don't know what
it is
okay binary prefixed or something i
don't know
oh that no i like that right binary
binary prefix that makes perfect sense
right
which we already have in alpha as a
physical
quantity systems right okay so fine so
this is a reasonable direction for these
okay i think i think um it's time to
why isn't this just a ray flattened
block diagonal matrix why isn't that
just a ray flatten
okay nobody's saying i think so i'm
enough i'm giving up here
i think this is just it's probably
constructable be
as per serving right
now on block diagonal sorry i didn't
read it brother
well it's not right yeah so it's right
so it does the padding for you to write
rather than you having to manually
construct
all of the the zero matrices that does
it for you
okay somewhat interesting
how can you determine if an expression
is a valid uuid
you mean just shape wise
i think there's nobody here to represent
these so i think it's time to wrap up
okay okay good stuff thanks a lot guys
see y'all soon